what's up guys
bang bang it is lunch money time while
while she's trying to get rich the rest
of us just trying to get our lunch money
right i'm not here
she's there with the beautiful
intelligent planet eviluva mayor nova
pompliano p-i-m-p
don't forget that lunch money is not
sponsored by block fight go get a block
fi account
you can earn up to 8.6 apy in their
interest bearing account
you can take out a us dollar loan
against your crypto collateral or you
can buy and sell crypto on a crypto
exchange
go check them out
blockbuy.comblockfy.com
pomp let's get it
oh let's get it okay so
i was a real bad lag there so goldman
sachs
um is moving from wall street to main
street
um it's started testing a new automated
investment
service ahead of a broader rollout early
next year
employees who sign on to the digital
service called marcus invest
will pay an annual management fee of
point 15
and basically um
that they uh so goldman's move is the
latest example of a shift toward main
street that began in 2016
with its marcus brand of personal loans
and savings account
the bank which is long catered to the
ultra wealthy
corporate officers and institutional
investors is seeking new sources of
revenue
away from trading and investment banking
everybody wants to be a technology
company and everybody wants to be
a financial company so you're getting
emerging at fintech
and so the traditional guys starting to
add lots of technology
and the technology guys are starting to
add lots of finance
so i'm okay with this because it's
actually
uh broadening their services to more
people
and that could help with the wealth and
equality gap
bingo i'm in cool all right
wow we said something positive about
goldman sachs i'm cool with goldman
goldman's cool with me we're cool
all right peloton has announced that it
intends to acquire
pre-core one of the world's largest
suppliers of commercial fitness
equipment um
the acquisition will be made via a deal
that's valued at a total of
420 million dollars and this helps
bellatown bring on a lot more
manufacturing capability
in a time when its order queue for its
tread and bike hardware
is deeper than ever smart vertical
integration
anything you can do to own more and more
that supply chain next is people are
going to start
onshoring their supply chains they're
going to start automating their supply
chains whatever they can do to get more
efficient to get more products out the
door
so they can fulfill demand welcome to
the amazon
playbook welcome to the amazon
playbook all right hold on i hit a
paywall but i know what it's about
oscar health insurance oscar is um
ready to go with an ipo it filed an sec
filing
2021 uh it's a great business what i
don't understand i would have to look
this up
is how much of oscar's business is
dependent on
obamacare and kind of what happened
there i think a lot of it is
but uh my guess is that they've got a
plan for
uh it not being involved just as much so
we'll see what happens but
uh look everyone wants to get to public
markets oscar currently sells individual
obamacare coverage in 29 markets in 15
states
it has about 420 000 health plan
enrollees across the country
that includes about 400 000 in
individual plans
so it you know it also entered medicare
advantage last year
it'll be interesting i mean given that
biden is
elected we'll see what happens with
uh health with uh insurance right yeah
sorry
i'm uh being distracted by uh my friend
here
is your four-legged friend yeah he's a
four-legged furry friend
cooper if you want to come over here all
right sorry sorry go ahead hey man hey
chill out
okay he just wants everyone to know that
look he's real excited
he's so excited hi cooper oh
do you think he remembers me nope all
right next
yes he does um apple is moving forward
with self-driving car technology and
started targeting 2024 to produce a
passenger vehicle
that include that could include its own
breakthrough battery technology
god we do not every everyone knew that
apple was going to do this at some point
i'm surprised it's going to take them so
long to get it out they say 2024
but look apple
gotta keep expanding their hardware i'm
concerned about the battery technology
component because imagine
you have to upgrade your car your
battery gets slower your car gets lower
you can only drive 20 miles an hour
well they can do over-the-air software
updates maybe
maybe but if you don't get a new battery
or car
you're out there no one's going to beat
tesla you don't think so apple versus
tesla
good luck okay softbank
filed on monday to raise 525 million
dollars to a blank check
company as the visions vision funds
managers joined the craze for the
listing
vehicles another spec guys spax packs
back
everyone keeps laughing at uh at
softbank but uh softbank is actually
doing pretty well this year
you know doordash i think they turned
like 500 million bucks into like 11
billion or something
like they're they're cranking along
let's see what happens we'll see what
happens
okay it's ask lunch money time if you
have a question
do hashtag asklm in the comments below
okay all right ready
ryan harmeyer asks one two questions
one what was the best christmas gift you
received growing up
and two what did you ask santa for this
year oh
i know mine so okay so i was like six
years old
and uh my family got me this little like
diary with the 101 dalmatians on the
cover
it was just like a notebook and i loved
it so much and i started writing in it
and i forced everybody like i would
write them a letter then go hand them
the notebook make them answer my letter
in the room
get it back right back to them really
crazy but i still have it and it's kind
of cool because
you know some of those family members
have passed away but i still have their
handwriting what about you
i don't remember a single gift that i
got for christmas
are you serious i
i really don't remember um i remember
like
you know like like a big one like no
i i can remember my parents my mommy's
always get me clothes and then i would
always tell like oh this one you know
uh we need to return it she's like why
i'm like oh we need to return it now
just get the money
so i didn't have to get the clothes oh
geez um
yeah i can't really remember i just used
to always tell her like i don't need
anything get stuff from my brothers
uh she used to get me presents i just
don't really like like none of them like
stick out my eyes
selfless of you i just i i just
was never into like physical thing like
i don't know maybe like a video game
or something like you know we got
nintendo 64
uh when i was real young i used to whoop
my brother's ass on that like
it was a crime scene how bad they were
and how good
i was we won't talk about that here but
a crime
scene well what did you ask santa for
this year anthony
santa's not uh whoa that was close that
was this kid's show
uh santa i wrote a letter to him i left
uh
i'm gonna leave milk and cookies out for
him kids if you're at home you should
write a letter to santa
if you write the letter then he has to
bring you what you want if you don't
write the letter he's not going to bring
it for you
um i asked for a
uh a bitcoin
all right i'm sure he'll get you plenty
of those for me
i um asked for eau de toilette
which is a perfume and
santa wrote back and told me you really
want
toilet spray for christmas because it
said
toilet spray so santa
if you're watching and you're listening
yes i want toilet spray for christmas
okay
yeah i missed that one okay go ahead ask
lunch money
from rayberry pomp what are your
thoughts on specs
wow how timely of a question investing
in the person
such as trim off and not necessarily an
idea sounds like a cool way of getting
in private companies
early what do you think so i don't know
if you're necessarily getting in private
companies early you're basically getting
in
private companies before they become
public companies well
earlier than most what kind of
um but you you definitely are just
betting on a management team and
that's what you do in early stage
investing that's what you do in you know
spack investing
and i tend to think that uh pert is my
personal opinion not financial advice
but uh i tend to think that chamoth is
incredibly talented he's very very smart
um and so far his track record is pretty
strong
and so you know he he's definitely an
interesting spac manager
um i think that there will be others um
and so it's just
you got to do your homework right you
got to educate yourself and be ready to
actually back the people you think can
can be successful
perfect sounds great all right
that's it all right we'll see you guys
tomorrow
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money as much as we did
and don't forget lunch money is now
sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to 8.6
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange i personally
use the interest bearing account
there's not very many places where
you'll find up to 8.6
interest on a deposit in an interest
bearing account go do your own research
there's risk associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends